So now we know that height is strongly heritable.
>> So, are you saying that there's a height gene?
>> Well, not exactly a single height gene.
The heritability values don't tell us about the
number or type of genes involved in a
given trait. Heritability values don't exactly tell us about
the genetic differences that could be contributing to
the trait themselves. For example, we don't know if
we're looking for a missense mutation, or nonsense
mutation, or chromosomal translocation some place in the genome.
>> So why should somebody still care about heritability?
>> Well, heritability can tell us if genetic factors
are involved at all, and actually might even be able
to tell us how easy it would be to
find out what those genetic factors are. For example, a
heritability close to one would signify that there are
probably a few genes responsible for the variability in the
trait, and that they have a strong influence This means
that we'd be able to perhaps find out what they
are even in a relatively small study
size. But the lower the heritability, the farther
away from one we get and the closer to zero, the more likely it is that
there are many genes that have an effect,
each with a smaller influence overall. And it
would take a much larger study size to
find the effects of those particular genetic factors.